ASSA coimbra's my name's Pierre
welcome to incident in Janos
it's a Brazilian horror game it's made
by the same guy who made PES adela and
it looks pretty crazy it looks pretty
awesome actually sanatory or i Fujio dos
Anjos
the insane refugee for old people
am i right my Spanish is this [ __ ]
flawless it's not even Spanish is for
the gays right okay but going in okay
estranja
para on their phone todo mundo nice name
that's fine whoa whoa whoa wow wow wow
those flowers are awesome oh whoa
flowers shut the [ __ ] up liars
oh oh the folks go flowers don't blink
what in the [ __ ] I am pretty sure I went
a flower school and they don't blink
like this I don't laugh either is this a
graphic bug or is in my ass but I
bogging in my body
oh it's a light [ __ ] light shut up
flowers I think I just got [ __ ] by one
of them hey this is better pool I don't
know no they don't hey hey hey I just
want to smell flowers well [ __ ] you when
your flowers then
I never liked you you sound like a
[ __ ] turkey yep really nice long arms
I never never complimented you all night
maybe that's the problem huh
people don't compliment you enough well
I think you are beautiful
okay okay okay I'm sorry about your
really what my phone
there weren't flowers on the walls okay
it's a graphical bug isn't it supposed
to happen okay I don't know what's going
on
well so we're using a cell phone this
game is really cool for bici it for me
whoa job puss whatever I guess we were
[ __ ] crazy I think we get cigarettes
to come or text yeah let me out of here
I wasn't bored in this cage I need to be
free oh oh hello if someone just [ __ ]
open me Madre de Dios
como rim parle Nast Eduardo hey now fine
don't let me finish okay it's working
now I'm happy about this this game is
really cool
like a mime my girl my homegirl I'm
using her to light up my holloway held
out schemas with jet hey hey Sharon how
you don't one get the [ __ ] over nice
keep dancing keep dying to chat keep
dying whatever okay okay you know way
back pears whatever Wow
I think that's our it's like amnesia we
lose our sanity while we go into [ __ ]
places in shape okay that was that place
was really cool I just wanted to look
smell a flower what the [ __ ] are you I'm
going this way going this way going this
way not going that way I'm sure it's
just something in my head and look it
was pounding the wall is it over here
stop it sir stop it we're trying to
sleep over here idiots
[ __ ] morons sherry go go aside step
aside daughter meet the audience that is
a nice picture that isn't even as a
picture that is YouTube's almost not
YouTube friendly mm-hmm if I was a girl
I would be doing this all day and laying
on to transcod oh well [ __ ] Amato
don't worry yeah it works oh this was an
open before lovely
is so cute begod okay well you gotta you
gotta wear time phones I keep telling
people tips how tips help us calm what
oh all right let's go a beer everybody
high five
whoa what the [ __ ] is that you'll honey
well that is it ah look I want my
flowers back how am i beautiful that is
just [ __ ] up you look stupid
Oh why do you do this why you do this
chair why
I'm tired of here they made me do it
well I don't give a [ __ ]
high five ow ow ooh nice the [ __ ]
you're coming with me now yeah you stay
there idiot that's right don't worry
breath it's just a game I'll [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] CC I'm [ __ ] Arcanist
hello excuse me I got lost with my car I
want to go back to Sweden this place is
so [ __ ] creepy
ene [ __ ] yeah
what does that guy want from me
I'm just being [ __ ] nice in shape I
just came for flowers and boobs
I got boobs and flowers but I want more
above for those please thank you you can
send to my facebook
don't tell my god about the flowers
anyway [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] really hard I am NOT
going inside it okay we're good sang-doo
Doris and qui games
hola hola
he's taking a shower we should not
interfere so what did you do today
I guess he's let's not go near him oh
this is the mannequin okay okay you calm
the [ __ ] down
you calm the [ __ ] down ah stop stabbing
me what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
people
you don't stop no you don't stop people
you don't stab people okay I'm sorry I
just want to check out your ass what
what the [ __ ]
stop oh [ __ ] die hey guys stop stabbing
people I'm innocent
hey guys good to see you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
all of you never liked it
oh oh no bueno no bueno
hey chair how you doing [ __ ] out of
that place oh this is [ __ ] dark oh
wow I like your haircut now you don't
have hair hello hello well a lot Tuerto
this phone doesn't really help Paul what
the [ __ ] is he doing
that guy has [ __ ] swagalicious nice
oh oh oh oh oh nope nope nope did he
[ __ ] nope oh [ __ ]
hello can someone please turn the lights
back on
thank you thank you cast eagle oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
thank you sir can I have your hooks too
I didn't expect that [ __ ] to happen
where do we use these probably to fix
electricity it's over here I know
because I know this and I'm okay oh
where the [ __ ] are we what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are you don't go to any Satan's
[ __ ]
don'tyou daegil near me I will [ __ ] you
shut up shut up shut up Terry
okay okay okay sister nightmare it's
just a nightmare it's not real it's not
real it's not real games can't hurt me
that's fine rainbows unicorns boobies
boobies boobies hug the walls but it's
been it's been great it's been it's been
so good I just want to hang out all the
time but I can't I got you know busy got
a schedule you know how it is these days
you try to make things work okay just
[ __ ] stop already I person I'm gonna
have Jen's here but leave a like if you
enjoyed watching had subscriber come
birthday and I'll see in the next one
sales and births love you oh he's done
it's dead now well what my hand is
[ __ ] possessed by a demon what that
Bach stop please I'm not even clicking
anything what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
look what you're doing